all right let's close out day one of our
80s celebration with something super
bright and cheery this is what i'm
liking
so y'all might remember that tie-dye saw
a huge resurgence in the 80s designers
even started incorporating unique
tie-dye patterns on runways worldwide
now a little boy in pennsylvania wants
to ensure the trend stays as popular as
ever he's making and selling his own
shirts but here's what makes him extra
special he's actually splitting the
profits with one of his favorite
charities let's get him on the line
right now say hi to six-year-old tuka
and his mama tiffany who watch on abc 23
in johnstown what's up y'all
i like your tata you look so good so how
did you get so into tie-dye tuka i got a
thai kit for my birthday
i saw other people do it on youtube and
it looked really cool i like you're like
my kids my kids are in love with
watching youtube things
so wait tell us about your business so
how did you make it into a business you
give some to charity right
yes
yeah do you have fun making this go
ahead i'm telling you about your
business i'm the ceo outside of my
hookah
i make
shirts
sweatshirts hoodies
bandanas for dogs baby onesies for dogs
and babies
oh my gosh why tell kelly why you're
making all of these
for a 2 000 lamborghini
[Laughter]
you first of all
this is news you just found a 2 000
lamborghini that's amazing everyone's
running out trying to find that right
now wait tell tell us about the business
of tiffany what do you do with it
so i am as he likes to call me his
personal assistant so mom and personal
assistant
um i work primarily on keeping track of
all of his orders um getting his inks
together i work on his facebook group um
right now that's the
the main place of uh getting these
shirts is his facebook group
he is definitely the ceo uh definitely
the boss he makes all the big decisions
um personal assistant over here to help
with whatever he needs i love that well
tuco like where do you give the money
who do you give the money to
i give the money to local charities
and tell kelly who you donated to first
your safe haven
tell them about your safe payment
they go buy gift cards and give the
money and give the gift cards to moms
and kids they don't have enough money to
buy groceries
oh that's so kind you have such a big
heart for such a young man
i love it thank you so much
thank you tiffany for joining us today
i'm liking your post right now right
that's right thank you
all right that's not all though our
season long partner pilot pin makers of
friction the go-to race will pin at the
kelly clarkson she'll want to celebrate
those creating fearlessly just like you
took us so they're going to give you a
thousand dollars how's that sound
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
you